Hey, Gagan.
Hey, Sarah. Hi, good afternoon, Morgan.
Hi, good afternoon, guys. How are you doing?
Good afternoon, Morgan. How are you?
I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. Another busy day. I know we've rescheduled this a couple times and Walter just had to literally go out to an on-site. So it is just me again, but I was like, I'm going. We're going to get it done. No more rescheduling. So happy to see you guys.
Okay.
Thank you, thank you for taking time out.
Well, happy to see you as well, and I truly, truly appreciate your, you know, despite being extremely, extremely busy, you still found time for this meeting.
No, I'm sure it's busy for y'all right now too. I'm like, we just need to get on here and get her done for sure.
Hi, thank you. Hi, Evan. Thank you for joining in.
Hey, Gagan. Hey, Morgan. Hey, Rob. How's everyone doing?
Hey? Good afternoon. Good. How are you?
Good afternoon. Great, great.
Thank you. Is Walter joining?
So, no.
It's just me. Walter had got to another on site and I was about to email you all and I was like, I think we've literally already rescheduled this two times. So we're just going to go and get this done today.
Ohh.
Okay.
All right.
We appreciate it. Thanks, thanks, Malig.
Of course, yeah. Thanks for being flexible with our reschedule too. I appreciate it.
All the credit goes to Gaurav.
OK, Gagan, over to you, my friend.
At the same time, I mean, you and everyone found time, you know, as for, you know, Morgan and, you know, our availability. So thank you, Sarah, and Kevin, you as well. Thank you. All right, so I hope, you know, as Kevin always says, even if you're busy, that's good, busy, so it's good. If things are moving in the right direction.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Exactly.
Alright, hope things are going fine at your end.
Yep, you can get over here.
All right, that's great. So I think we can get it going. Let me quickly share my screen. Sarah, sorry, would you like to add anything before we start the presentation?
No, no, please go ahead. That's fine.
Okay, thank you.
Can you please let me know once it's there on your screen?
Yes, it is.
I can see it.
Thank you, so.
Nothing much changed on the first slide except this is from May to June. We are doing it in the month of June. However, we'll be reviewing Maverick's performance for the month of May. So agenda items, nothing much changed. So we have highlights, performance analysis, ITBD, CSAT, way forward with think unified.
AI by Design, our ITBD initiative, holiday schedule, and of course, recap that we share with minutes of meeting after this call. And Morgan, please feel free to chime in as you always do. We would love to see your active participation. So whenever...
Whenever you have any insights, feedback, or suggestion about anything that we that we are reviewing today, OK? And this is for everyone. Thank you.
Okay.
Not much, but I captured some of the highlights. I know.
In this week, so sorry, in this May month. So thank you, first of all, for accommodating some time, you know, to Maverick so that he could enjoy his bachelorette, you know, with his with his friends. I mean, I don't know whether...
Yeah.
He has disclosed or not, so he's he's planning to get married, hopefully this year, if...
Yeah, he was telling me that. That's very exciting. I'm super excited for him. That's awesome.
Yeah.
So initially, I was, you know, my intention is always to not to have major impact on the business. So I was asking to, I mean, why do you need these much leads and finally? So I mean, if you can just come back in two days, I will be fine. You still have two days. So he said, no, this is really going to be a one-time opportunity for his life. And after marriage, it may not be
Mhm.
Yep.
possible because we both have to decide together and you know, both of our plans will be together, you know, with each other. So this is the time I want to spend with my close friends. So he shared a few pictures. Das location was really, really exotic. Hale station.
Yeah.
with a lot of snowfall. I mean, yeah, they were, I mean, until me, they were completely drowned in the snow. Okay. That was pretty good to see that. So thank you again for approving his lease for one week. And he exceeded.
Mhm.
for the remaining 3 weeks. He exceeded his TRR ticket result rate in the first two weeks. And in the last fourth week, we'll review in the further slides.
And yeah, I see that he has been consistent in creating, updating SOPs, but I would love to hear from you, Morgan. You work very closely with him, who is doing, how he did in the month of May SPU.
What?
Sorry, say again, I think it cut out at the end of what you were saying. I thought you were still talking.
Okay, I'm sorry. So I just wanted to hear from you. I mean, what are your observations of how he had been in the Mohti Banmeet, as per you?
Oh. Yeah.
So in May, yeah, especially. I've only seen improvements for the most part. We had some like bigger tickets come in. Like right now, I think he's working on what I call like a P2. I think it's been a raising the system since I had to jump in here. But his communication on things has gotten a lot better. Not that it was ever like.
bad or anything like that, but I know that was something we were looking to see, the timeliness on getting updates out, good agreements, been changing and stuff like that. So just filling in smaller details that were never like major things, but yeah, it's been going well. I haven't had a lot to bring to him and his one-on-ones about anything.
So, that I have with him at least.
Great. Thank you for sharing. Yeah, because you always know it's not that when we're meeting after a month, so please feel free to share. You can always give me a call or drop me an email separately as well. And if there's anything that he needs improvement on, he needs attention.
Yeah.
Mhm.
So we'll definitely work closely with them and we'll bring those things up to speed and to the level that requires attention.
Yeah.
Thank you. Moving on to performance analysis in comparison to the previous previous month to that, that is April. In the month of April, so yeah, we can see his utilization, billable utilization in the first two weeks, as I said, so that remains 63.
percent and 71 percent is the billable number and non-available tasks remain 37 percent and 29 percent.
Yeah.
So, what I was discussing with him during my board review is that why his why your non-billable time is increasing and the billable time is is not touching ITBD is target of close to 80%. So, he told me that you know there was...
little drop in ticket inflow that they observed in the month of May and
So whenever he had lesser time, so he contributed that time into some security trainings, I believe, which were, so I think maybe he spoke to you or Walter, so he included himself in some security trainings.
Kam.
Mhm.
I believe he does his job with maturity. So I just need some basic, not so basic, some major, you know, key pointers where attention is required. So sometimes I connect once or twice a week with him just to understand how.
Okay.
how things are moving, if they're moving in a right direction, I'm good with that. Or if you think.
Yeah, yeah, everything's been good. I think on the Helpdesk, we've had less and more on our like change manage setup side. It's been pretty heavy. So he's kind of just been like holding on the floor on Helpdesk. So these numbers do kind of trace with how things are going right now, honestly.
Sure, thank you. And yeah, please feel free to let me know if there's anything that needs attention. We're from Maverick side, but maybe he is not unintentionally, he is not looking at those things, so we can bring his attention or, you know, towards those particular pieces.
Yeah.
which can be worked upon.
So thank you. That is it in terms of billable and productivity standpoint. We know that, so moving on to the other side, others like, so in the third week when he was out, so we are understandable, he worked only on Monday, which is on May 18th, so which is why you see he worked on only 6 tickets that day and was still.
was able to complete 4 tickets. And in the remaining 3 weeks, so he was able to touch 31 and was able to result out of that. So blue bar represents the number of tickets he touched and the green one is the number of tickets he completed, knocked down.
In the second week, he test 39, was able to resolve 32. We already talked about week third, week 4th, he test 37 and completed 28 tickets. I believe from...
Ticket resolve rate standpoint, just because of the weak third, I mean, although the number was small, which is why if he had touched one more ticket, the number could have jumped from 67% to higher, much higher. So his percentage, you know, could have been with just one ticket, percentage could have.
jump from 78% to at least, I would say if I'm not wrong, 85 or 86%.
So that is it. In total, he touched 113 tickets and was able to resolve 89, and we know that. So once for going forward, once he'll be working full-fledged for all four weeks, I'm sure ticket numbers will be back on track from June onwards.
Um...
Yeah, if we see a comparison with April. So in April he had touched 177 and we clearly see the difference. So there's a difference of almost 40 tickets, 50 tickets. So I think this is because of those three days. So he can easily pull up. We understand the reason behind that.
Anything from your end, Morgan?
No, nothing from me.
Okay. Thank you.
I truly appreciate whatever he is doing in your environment. So you appreciate his efforts he's putting in. And yeah, so we do receive timely feedback, monthly CSAT from you. So truly appreciate that. So he did receive a positive CSAT for the month of April as well as for the month of May as well.
It's definitely.
So thank you to your team as well, Morgan, especially to you. You are the one who we direct our CSAT, monthly CSAT too. Thank you.
Way forward, I don't think much. As I said, so my emphasis, my goal is only to keep Maverick's productivity on track and keep supporting him wherever he needs assistance. Yeah, so wherever he thinks, beyond his KRAs, KPIs,
If we can add value in terms of adding, creating SOPs or maybe creating some boards, you need assistance in cleaning some boards or anything else, maybe some taking escalations or when the other person is out and some more tasks can be put on his plate. So this is all.
where you can add value or maybe something more that you can think of. So that is it. And just to keep our team united and feel like they're working at home with their families. So yeah, we do organize these collaborative activities so that.
Yeah.
Um, we go out and, yeah, you know, dine together, have lunch or dinner together.
Please do also let us know if you observed anything. Maybe because why I'm asking is I know what is his order doing. I mean, good as per your expectations, but sometimes we may have some new logos added or some new partners may have different requirements in there.
Mhm.
businesses. For instance, some may have more Azure work wherein a team is not equipped fully. So those kind of things. If you think you need some skill set upgradation, so.
Okay, yeah, I will let you know.
I will train Maverick on those things.
Cool. Perfect.
Thank you.
By the way, have you reserved your ticket for Build It already? You're your team?
No, I don't think any of us will be going.
Is there a specific reason, Morgan?
If I, if I may ask, I mean, yeah.
I'm sorry, what was that?
Is there any specific reason we're just training you to join the event? I believe you guys have been participated in the event earlier. Okay.
I mean, we're in the middle of an acquisition, so that's our focus right now is bringing on all our new clients and getting the team assimilated. So I don't really think we're looking to do anything like that.
Thank you. I hear you. And anyone from your leadership team apart from you or Walter, would you like to send someone on your behalf?
I don't think that would be an option for us right now, but I appreciate it.
Sure. The reason why I'm asking is in case, in case, let's say, if I know completely understandable that when merger, when you're going through a merger, obviously the focus would be there. But currently we have a complimentary offer for our partners. Just to keep you apprised, I will send you the code so that if someone else would like to.
to join in for the event, you will be able to get a complimentary ticket. I have sent you the details in the chat window so that you can go through the code and I'm also sharing the agenda because the focus currently will be on the AI along with the growth with the leadership.
and business intelligent. So feel free to let me know in case if there is someone who would like to join in, we would love to have you there.
Okay.
And I would just like to add, I mean, yeah, I would just like to add this is not far away, Morgan, you know, this is just one flight away.
Erest Gagan.
Yeah, I believe you are already in Texas, right?
Vikram.
Yeah, just one flight, I mean, from Texas to New Jersey.
Mhm.
Okay, so we understand there are some business exigencies, you know, that you need to take care of. We completely understand, but yeah, so...
We do have, so whenever we have any opportunities, so which is why we are sharing, so, you know, this is what ITBD shares with with its partners.
because our main focus is AI. This is emerging in the market these days and how we should be equipped with all sort of knowledge about AI, including how we can do our work with more efficiency, at the same time how we can keep our environment secure because
Yeah, we know that some zero-day threats and everything, I mean, those are also increasing because of AI, so teams should be equipped. And this is for LMA layer, which is a leadership layer. They should also be well equipped with all kind of AI and many other, I believe, sort of.
I will not be touching more on this because we already heard from you, but there are other market leaders are also coming, for instance, Hello, PS and other vendors who you may get an opportunity to interact with.
That is it. So thank you, Morgan, for sharing your views on that. So moving on to AI by design, I believe this has already been shared with the team, sir, if I'm not wrong.
Yes, that's already been taken care, Gagan. Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
And...
Morgan, have you ever taken demo? I know we'll repeat this slide, you know, every time, but we need to understand, as you're in the middle of acquisition, so you may have some requirements of gauging, you know, taking group meetings, employee engagement activities, and rewards recognition, and managing, you know, bigger teams. So, if you're...
Mm.
currently using a tool. If you have recently deployed a tool, you know, that must be great. But if you have been using a tool for a long time, I must say you must at least see a demo so that you understand what this tool brings to resolve.
issues or struggles that you may be experiencing at the moment. Okay. So whenever you have 30 minutes, you can schedule a demo with our team and they will let you know what we have in for you.
Ohh.
And so as of now, you must have, I believe, compulsory holidays already marked on your calendar. So about optional holidays. So as of now, Maverick has decided to take Diwali, which is one of the biggest
of festivals in India, which is on November 9th. So he'll be taking that off on that day.
And the other thing is, the other one is November 24th, Tuesday, good put up. So these can be mine. However, we will let you know at least two weeks in advance before these holidays approach.
Any questions about that, Morgan?
No.
No questions.
Thank you from presentation standpoint, but we are open for discussion, anything that we may or may not have covered. So we are open for discussion, Megan. Morgan, anything from your end overall.
Nothing from me. I appreciate that, guys.
Is there anything apart from Maverick within our, you know, me being his lead or a leadership team or marketing team, is this true with anything?
Not that I can think of, but if anything comes up, I will email you guys and let you know.
Yeah, feel free to let us know because not everything has money involved in it. Even if there's a minor change or minor help, maybe for a particular piece you need, so we'll always be willing to assist you in those particular pieces.
Okay.
Yeah.
great to keep in mind. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you. So that was committee all from my end. Sarah, Kavan, anything from your end?
No, I'm all good, Gagan. Thank you. Thank you once again, Morgan. And just one thing which I would like to share that in case if there is anything at all, no matter how small it is, feel free to share it with us over Teams. We guys are just a text away. So think of us as a part of your extended team.
Nope, all good. Thanks, Kris.
Mm.
Thank you guys, I appreciate it.
Share with me, share with me first, and I will communicate to Sarbjeet.
Just on a lighter note, I'm saying this. So thank you, team, for joining in. Thank you, Morgan, for taking the time out. So I'm glad that we were, as you were busy, so we were able to wind up this meeting in just 21 minutes. So I'm glad. So thank you, team, for joining in. We shall meet.
the next meeting with more positive and fruitful updates. So thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Morgan, and have a good one. Goodbye.
Thank you.